[Music]
throughout history particular cities
have played a very important asterism
Rome London Philadelphia and you can
kind of mark the great stages of history
in the great developments of human
Liberty by those places the American
place that was created as a result of
what happened in Philadelphia
is Washington DC
Washington DC is where the action is if
you want to affect our federal
government this is where you have to be
and there are so many opportunities to
make a change I move to Washington to
change things to improve and advance
American government this is where laws
are made this is where policy happens
it's a place that represents the idea of
America and a capital of one of the
greatest countries in the world in
history and this is the place to change
the country graduate programs in
Washington DC are about a dime a dozen
there are lots of them and most of them
teach you to accommodate yourself to the
status quo how Washington works today we
want to do something different we want
to teach you how to think so you know
those first principles and you're able
to have good judgment and deliberate and
take action these days culture tells us
to react to respond and it's all based
on feeling based on hype
I want the change I am part of to be
substantive and to be thoughtful and
there has to be a grounding what's
missing in a lot of politics today is we
tend to have one or the other we have a
lot of people that want to talk about
first principles and of course we have a
lot of people that want to focus just on
action it's connecting the two that's
the virtue of statesmanship education is
about more than just turning out good
workers it should be about turning out
good citizens as well the next
generation of Americans who understand
the timeless principles of our
government and unfortunately too many
schools and special universities not
only fail in that mission but they
actively repudiate that mission young
people who come to this town don't have
that founding understanding of how
government should be and how it will
best operate
so I'm excited about learning the larger
story and how to incorporate the wisdom
of people who came before us into a very
fraught culture right now
this graduate school was inspired by
George Washington to teach these things
the large things that a statesman would
need to know to govern this country well
we're gonna look at core documents
original documents we're gonna study the
writings and thoughts of great statesmen
and great books and it will mostly be
taken by people who work in the
government and they will read old books
they'll start with Plato and Aristotle
Herodotus and Thucydides and they'll
learn what politics is and then they'll
learn what America is
[Music]
this program is unique because it
marries political thought and philosophy
and wisdom from the agents with
governance and statesmanship where we
are now there's a reason why people
study old texts they've proven their
value but they're also rigorous and so
you really can't you can't dumb them
down we want to study that now not
because it's the past we must study it
because the past will help us now to
shape the future
[Music]
what the Van Andel Graduate School of
Government wants to do is help you see
the North Star because if you don't have
that why you involved in politics
[Music]
what excites me most about teaching here
I think would have to be the opportunity
to be what Socrates called Pro triptych
the turning of souls I really think that
this school of government and this
curriculum and these teachers this place
this town you can actually turn people
towards a life of deep and prudent
service if you give them the right
principles and give them the right tools
[Music]
we are in many ways in a crisis today
about who should govern are we still a
self-governing people the role of
Congress versus the president the
supreme court consent these are the core
questions that actually go back to the
very founding itself
and as an extension of our teaching
mission it's only natural that we are
going to teach those ideas which we've
taught from the very beginning here in
this city to all those who wish to
perpetuate Liberty in today's world
we want to live freely that's not so
easy these days right we do huge things
we don't take any money from the
government why because we think it's a
paternity value and we think we have a
right to it and so we need a freedom to
let us do
[Music]
there will be many difficult and prudent
decisions required to recover a stronger
sense of self government in limited
government and constitutional government
it's going to take some time but we
prepare now to shape those people who
will do that it's not too late I want to
see the next generation of American
statesmen prepared to face those
challenges should they come and the
lessons they learn are being taken out
of the classroom at Hillsdale and I mean
taken into the halls of Congress and
into the administration and into the
courts the greatest thing that the Van
Andel Graduate School of Government in
Washington DC can accomplish is to form
a corps of individuals who have the
knowledge and the determination the good
sense the prudence going out into the
world in order to turn it to turn it
back to its principled course for the
good of preserving self-government
forming those kinds of individuals
statesmen and be able to teach them and
see them formed would be the greatest
accomplishment
and for the good of our country
[Music]
you